You may have heard about special right triangles before. They're special,
because they have a 90 degree angle for one of their angles. We're going to
take a closer look at this one. It's a 3, 4, 5 right triangle. We call it that,
since the ratio of the legs is 3 to 4 and the hypotenuse is 5. The legs are
just the sides of the triangle that form the right angle. And the hypotenuse is
the side that is directly across from the 90 degree angle. Not only is the
hypotenuse across from the 90 degree angle, it's also the longest side of the
entire triangle. We're going to look at an interesting relationship between the
legs of the triangle and the hypotenuse. I'm going to shrink the triangle, and
then I'm going to draw boxes off of each of the legs and the hypotenuse. These
boxes are actually squares, so this square has side lengths of three, this
square has side lengths of four, and this square has side lengths of five. What
I want you to do is to tell me the area of each of these squares. You can type
those numbers here.